kill every Targaryen
everyone who isn't us
is an enemy
so Ilyn bring me his head we take what
is ours
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in A
Song of Ice and Fire video today I want
to talk about the five characters George
RR Martin's said would survive his story
all the way back in 1993 George wrote a
3-page letter that outlined his original
plans for a Song of Ice and Fire
he wrote this out just a few years
before his first book a game of Thrones
was published back then his plans for
the story were very different than what
it ended up becoming for those of you
who have not read his original outline I
will put the link down below that way
you can take a look at it for yourself
even though most of it did change it's
still very interesting to get a glimpse
into the story they could have been a
Song of Ice and Fire he still kept some
of the main themes and all of the
characters that he mentioned but most of
them died under very different
circumstances then he originally planned
just as an example he intended on having
Rob die in battle and Joffrey get maimed
on the battlefield but as we all know
Rob died during the red wedding he also
intended on having Catelyn get killed by
the others beyond the wall but we know
she ended up dying at the red wedding
with Rob like I said he still included
all of the characters from his outline
but he did change the direction of their
individual stories one of the most
interesting things from these three
pages is who George said would survive
the entire story back nanny said five
central characters will make it through
all three volumes he only planned on
running a trilogy but even that changed
he goes on to say in a sense my trilogy
is a generational saga telling the life
stories of these five characters three
men and two women the five key players
are tearing in Lannister Daenerys
Targaryen in three of the children of
Winterfell Arya Stark bran stark and the
bastard Jon Snow at the time these were
the only characters George was willing
to say would survive all of the events
to come this revelation caused a debate
between fans because some say these
characters are no longer safe because
George has already changed so much of
this outline but other people say George
would never change the outcome of his
key players
I have even went back and forth on
deciding whether these characters would
live or not both arguments may
some good points but I recently came
across something that may give some more
insight about whether we should believe
any of this outline or not there is a
website called so spake Martin and it's
basically an archive of everywhere
spawns George has ever given regarding A
Song of Ice and Fire as I was on there
reading someone's urges responses to
questions I came across his response to
this outline being leaked on Twitter and
George had some very interesting things
to say about the validity of these three
pages he does admit that this is his
outline but he pretty much says we
should not believe any of it I will post
a link to this conversation down below
as well that way you can read it for
yourself if you would like but I want to
read what he said because this could be
a clue about the fate of these five
characters I believe this conversation
happened while they were attending some
kind of donation dinner possibly for
charity but I'm not exactly sure
it just says donation dinner but this is
what was said I begin writing these
books in 1991 and then I got a TV play
so I put the books aside to really work
on doorways which was a TV pilot and I
did a TV show in 92 to 93 in 1994 I
returned to the books and worked on it
you know up until then in my career as a
writer
I'd always written the entire book
before I hopped it for sale that is
unusual because most writers do chapters
in an outline they write a few chapters
they outline the rest of the book then
they give that to the publisher and the
publisher says okay I'll take that as
some of you may have noticed those who
have been paying very very careful
attention I'm not good with deadlines
and I'm not good with outlines either I
always hated outlines so with fever
dream and with Armageddon rag and with
dying of the light and all about
I wrote the entire book before I turned
it in I did not do chapters and outlines
I sat down I wrote a whole book and I
sent it to my agent and said look here's
the whole book and it's finished that
way I don't have a deadline it would be
finished before it even went on the
market and that worked well for me my
initial thought was to do this the same
way but what happened was in 1994 when I
returned to the books I was very
enthused about it and I said to myself I
really want
right these Game of Thrones books but I
was still in Hollywood and I just lost
all this ground work on doorways the TV
pilot but the studios and network still
wanted to work with me
so I was getting other offers like we
want you to write this movie we want you
to do another TV pilot and you know I
took a couple of them and was still
thinking oh god I'm going to have to put
the book away again cuz I had no
deadline for the book
a game of Thrones so I said to myself
look if I want to get back to being a
novelist I'm gonna have to sell this
even though it's not finished so I had
my 200 pages of Game of Thrones at that
point but they wanted an outline I told
them I don't do outlines I don't know
what's gonna happen I figure it out as I
go along
and that's how I always did it but they
said no we have to have an outline so I
wrote two pages a two-page thing about
what I thought would happen it'll be a
trilogy it'll be three books Game of
Thrones The Dance with Dragons and the
winds of winter
those were the three window titles and
uh it'll be three books and this will
happen and this will happen and this
will happen
I was literally making [ __ ] up and I had
a thought that those two pages were long
forgotten because of course the books
did sell they sold in the United States
and in Great Britain both they sold for
enough money that I didn't have to take
any more Hollywood games so I said no I
don't want any more movies or TV shows
I'm gonna write these books now so I
started writing the books and in the
process I pretty much disregarded the
outline the characters took me off in
entirely different directions so for 20
years I had forgotten that the to page
thing even existed but then someone at
HarperCollins got a new office building
and new conference rooms big conference
rooms that were decorated with books and
stuff like that they ended up naming the
conference rooms after the writers and
in one of the conference rooms they put
up these plastic display cases including
the outline they didn't even ask my
permission they just put it up you know
I was pretty pissed that the outline got
out there that should not have happened
outlines and letters like that are meant
only for the eyes of the editor they
should not go on public display
you
all right so as you can see George is
basically saying that outline was made
only for the purposes of getting the
ball rolling on completing the books if
what he said here was true then that
means he pretty much just made things up
so he could turn in an outline and get
the project sold he literally says I was
making up [ __ ] I said this will happen
and this will happen and this will
happen which basically means he was just
saying yada yada yada now of course you
could say George has to say things like
this that way he can cast some doubt
over the outline that way people won't
know any of his intentions of how the
story will end when you consider how
much has already changed from the
outline I don't think it's out of the
realm of possibility that he could kill
off some of those five key characters
for good some could even argue that
George has already foreshadowed some of
the characters deaths depending on how
you interpret the text from the books I
do however find it odd that George was
so pissed
this was leaked if he was just making
[ __ ] up like he says then why should he
worry about it being made public
he already changed most of it so what is
the problem if you was really just
making [ __ ] up by saying this will
happen and that will happen and this
will happen then you shouldn't have to
worry about something getting spoiled
I do believe most of these five
characters will live throughout each
book but I would not bet that all of
them will regardless of what George has
to say about the outline Jon Snow could
easily die in battle as well as Arya
Stark now some people think just because
Arya is George's wife's favorite
character that means she is destined to
live but I would not be so sure about
that there are also theories about bran
stark dying once magic comes to an end
and there are theories about bran being
than I came which would mean Jon would
most likely have to kill him there are
just so many different possibilities I
have made a video about this outlined
before so I don't want to repeat
anything from the other video but I
wanted to show you what George had to
say about it because I had never seen
his response before until I came across
it last night let me know what you think
about some of the things he said do you
really believe he was just making things
up in order to turn in an outline
or do you think he's just trying to
mislead us into believing it's all wrong
I don't want to call George a liar but
since he was still mad about it being
posted that makes me question what he
had to say about it are all five of
these characters still going to live or
is george trying to make us think they
are in just as much danger as some of
the minor characters put all your
thoughts on this down below in the
comment section I want to thank everyone
for watching the video I really
appreciate that and don't forget the
links are down below just in case you
want to double-check any of this for
yourself also before I go I want to
thank all of my supporters on patreon I
hope everyone has a great day I will see
you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]